I was just wondering because you entered
upon this adventure with no experience
in education nonprofit work I was
wondering what major challenges you
faced and was there ever a moment at
which you really questioned the
foundations of what you were doing and
what made you keep going wow I think the
hardest thing was probably the first
making the decision and I just did made
that by talking to a lot of people and
having support one thing that I haven't
talked about as my husband who has
supported me off through all of it and
if he had been against it or hadn't
really supported me who knows what would
happen but there was a time in 2005 when
we had actually built the building and
it got stolen from us and by a rival
middle school came and took over the
hour day the day we inaugurated the
building they came up and took it over
this kind of drunken crowd and that was
kind of a big disappointment and I ever
that I think the lesson I learned was
why do we have to build a building first
we only had a few students we should
have just put him in a house somewhere
that was a big lesson and important but
it was John I think that kept me coming
back that year because it was a hard
year as we went that was just the
beginning of problems within the
community sort of a fight that I had to
just remove myself from making one at
you know trying to urge people to do
stuff because I mean I my instinct was
it can't take our school but they didn't
want to they didn't see it that when
they have to live there too they didn't
they we gave up the school we still
don't have it that we've built another
school but that was hard